everybody welcome to the Development
Committee 22nd of November 2018 as usual
our emergency evacuation announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building by the nearest available exit
to the chamber our assembly point will
be in the public car park at the side of
the Civic suite please don't delay your
bill your evacuation to collect any
belongings and please don't return into
the building until given permission to
do so by council staff please also note
that the meeting will be audio recorded
item one is apologies for absence
they've been received from councillor
Yano and item to substitute member such
counsel Lucas Gill non-members her
attending counselor mr. hoi item four
minutes of the meeting count on the 18th
of October 2018 you happy for me to sign
those as a correct and accurate record
of that meeting thank you
declarations of interest mrs. hoi cancel
mrs. Howe it's nice to Hoyt the same as
council music saying on computer Thank
You Williams I'm chairman yet I'm not
peeking really interesting right item
eight has been a portfolio out of the
environment Thank You members we've had
counselor mrs. Hall was it pecuniary or
non-pecuniary and then the nature of the
interest okay thank you members there is
an addendum that's been published and
circulated has everyone seen that and
had proper chance to digest the contents
yeah right thank you very much right
item six is land between Starr Lane and
Alexandra Road south of High Street
great Wakering thank you chairman
is it going yeah
apologies about that I'm okay the
application site is located outside the
certain look great wake room yeah
patience I outlined it in red if you can
see outline red here kind of in the
middle with the saya on the plan for you
illustrates that the site forms part of
a wider site currently under
construction known as star lane phase 2
which is outlined in blue so that's the
bold line the volta line around the edge
of the site to the west the site is
bounded by star lane Industrial Estate
beyond which is star lane to the
southwest is a former star lane
brickworks which is now housing
development presently under construction
by Taylor Wimpey East London directly
south the application site is darling
pits which are designated as a like cool
wildlife site to the east is an area
scrubland I'm on to site layout plan
planning for planning permission is
being sought for the construction of 78
dwellings 58 of these dwellings have
previously been considered these plots
are either being thought substituted or
real re orientated these changes for
pros would enable 20 additional
dwellings on site number of dwellings on
this site would increase from 180 to 200
dwellings over the entire phase to
development the principle of residential
development and the site access was
established within the outline Planning
Commission these matters are there
therefore not subject to further
assessment the site is divided into
character areas following the design
guide previously approved at a reserve
matter stage 78 dwellings would comprise
two or two-and-a-half storeys in height
and a mix of 1 to 5 bedroomed weddings
which is distributed across the site the
layout provides a density of 29 Wellings
per hectare in terms of design the
appearance scale bulk and higher layout
would follow on from phase 2 resulting
in a cohesive form of development
the dwellings proposed meets national
space standards as well as providing and
equipped private amenity space measuring
the course with the council's MSPD to
housing design
there is adequate back-to-back distances
between existing and proposed dwellings
as well as adequate sight sight
distances the layout would not result in
overlooking overshadowing or over
dominance on the private amenity space
or the existing and proposed dwellings
the proposed development provides a
level of car parking that is in
accordance with the private car parking
standards and will meet the demands of
the future occupiers whilst also
providing adequate car parking for
visitors the proposed dwellings would
not result in a dimensional harm from
the wider development nor the
surrounding character and appearance of
the area the proposal would not cause an
impact upon the amenity of surrounding
neighboring properties normally it posed
a threat to future occupants and
provides car parking provision that
would not be detrimental to highway
safety it's therefore considered that
the proposed development is in a call is
is compliant with policies of watcher'
district council local develop framework
you promo parking standards and the MPP
F it is recommended that committee
results of Planning Commission be
approved subject to a deed of variation
to the section 106 the variations in 626
relates to affordable housing
the increase in 20 additional dwellings
result in seven additional affordable
units seventy four units would be
available across the entire site
compliant with 35% required by council
policy these units would be split eight
to twenty six these units would be
associative rented of one but would be
immediate housing part with the council
policy and open space the developer has
agreed to a 25,000 contribution towards
existing place facing great Waker in
this summer's expect to be paid prior to
first occupation of the 78 dwellings
within the red line of the application
site and education a proportionate
increase tools early years and children
primary and secondary education and
secondary transport is required for the
additional twenty dwellings as well as
the habitat regulations assessments as
detailed in the addendum for you
the council's can as competent authority
has carried out a habit eight regulation
assessment and requires a hundred pound
per dwelling and which is 20 in total
thank you thank you have a speaker on
this one mr. Carson
[Music]
[Music]
Thank You chair and good evening
councillors I do not wish to repeat
anything from the officers presentation
so I'll try and keep this brief
the replan of star lane that you're
considering this evening is necessitated
by a number of factors at the site and
the application in front of you is a
result of detailed discussions with
offices of district council whilst we're
on the whole pleased with progress on
site at star line sales over recent
months have been below expectations the
most popular house type by far are the
3-bedroom properties whilst the larger
3-4 budget for bedroom units have proven
to be extremely difficult to sell this
is therefore not simply a case of
increasing the capacity to increase
revenue but to replan to be responsive
to the market and provide the types of
homes that people actually want to live
in in doing so this makes for a more
suitable development that also further
satisfies the broader objectives of the
national planning policy framework aside
from the benefits of providing more
appropriate and much needed homes there
are also additional benefits for the
wider area 7 of the additional homes
will be affordable provided in social
rent and intermediate offer we will also
be able to revisit the legal agreement
for the scheme and have already
informally agreed to a significant
contribution towards open space
improvements at the existing nearby
recreation ground proportionate
education contributions will also be
made should you be mindful to approve
the scheme the plans satisfy all policy
requirements on highway capacity car
parking space standards and including a
private amenity the scheme was
originally designed to be relatively
loose in form and whilst density and
capacity has increased in the replan it
remains a relatively low density scheme
@ 29.3 dwellings per hectare this does
bring the scheme more in line with local
policy dm2 whilst also satisfying the
MPPs wider requirements to make the most
efficient use of site allocations we
have now built over 100 new homes as
part of the first phase an employed of
vast number of local people in the
process
we hope that Taylor Wimpey have fully
demonstrated how seriously we take our
commitment
managing the construction stage in order
to be the best possible neighbors to
existing residents granted has not been
easy with a particularly warm summer but
where issues have arisen
we have been quick to respond and
rectify them we hope to continue to
build on this work we have completed so
far in great wagering and continue to
reinvest in the local workforce we want
to ensure the scheme as successful as it
can be and the replan will help to
achieve this thank you again and I look
forward to listening to the debate Thank
You chairman point of clarification as
much as anything please on looking at
the drawing there to the north top
corner of where the development site is
there's an access way through to the
high street what I'd like to do is to
clarify whether that will be opened up
as part of this project
once the site is occupied because that
comes out on the main High Street right
opposite the or just adjacent to the dr.
surgery bus stops and all the other
amenities it doesn't really come into
this development site here but I would
like to propose that that is the case
because otherwise the group of people
that will be living in that development
site will be completely cut off from the
high street
I think that's quite challenging because
it's not actually part of the
application that we're discussing but if
you'd like to yeah that access under the
high street is emergency access only and
there are pedestrian walkthroughs that
people can access the high street by a
foot or like say is an emergency access
only for vehicles yes just to clarify I
didn't mean for pedestrian and cyclist
so that will be happening as part of
that project thank you Casta hoc way
Thank You chairman
such a slight - Oscar obviously this
adjustment to the original scheme
increases number of dwellings is it also
corresponding increase in the number of
bed spaces what is the comparison
between bed spaces to the original
scheme and bed spaces to this scheme it
will increase bed spaces but I don't
actually have to hand how many bed
spaces it will increase by in the
addendum there is a table which outlines
the dwellings and what was previously
proposed private affordable when how
many dwellings are being proposed now
private affordable but it doesn't
actually refer to the bed bed spaces
specifically and so I don't actually
have the answer to give you but it would
increase the bed spaces of course trying
to come back
thank you cheering yeah yeah I think
this although it might seem a minor
point it's quite relevant in respect of
how the impact it has obviously the
number of people living on on the site
you know how many more people are likely
to be living on site as opposed to what
was originally proposed
I mean I think in respect of the
increased number of people living on the
site yes there's an increased number of
bed spaces we don't know the exact
figure and the policy looks for
contributions to in the section 106 is
going to deal with additional and
education contributions and the like
that would be linked to that increase on
the site but we say all in all that
there's a appropriate amount of open
space that's provided and this
application also seeks to address the
the contribution towards the the place
base in the sort of wider locality okay
that's a look at scale
thank you German can I refer to item six
point three on page six point one one
the reference to physical security from
Essex place
will this be pushed forward sorry thanks
comment school I have been put forward
to the agents they are aware of the
Comets promise its place
um it's matter between the applicant and
its place to resolve those issues
because it refers refers to design and
safety so luckily the applicant is aware
of it and it's it's dancing to just had
those discussions at the place in terms
of maybe putting some mitigation in
regarding so where is on straight safety
obviously where would be more lighting
etc but the applicant is aware of that
Thank You chairman yes of just to for
something else I'm I may have missed it
in the report was possible whereas going
through this sorry yes I it may be
something that might have missed in
report when I was going through it when
this came before us before in the
developers took some things on board
when we were in discussions with them
in in the pre-application period one of
which was to make the site Hedgehog
friendly I'm just wondering as to
whether this adjustment has any bearing
on that or whether it still meets our
requirements of a hedgehog friendly site
it will be Hedgehog friendly I have seen
within the ecology statement that's been
smitten Sparta's application that the
previous equality report has been
adopted and they will be following that
which allows for holes even fences for
hedgehogs to free herb to pass very
freely this will also be carried forward
into this development as well so it will
again be a child-friendly okay members
because we would put on a previous
occasion had significant debate about
the principle of this this is
essentially what we're looking at here
is do the additional 20 units fit within
that scheme and I think we've we've had
that sir the officers case clearly made
was so there's a recommendation for
approval
starting on on 6.1 and going through
plus the revision on the addendum
regarding the section 106 so can I ask
those members in favor of approval
please indicate that item is approved
thank you very much
item seven cherry orchard brickworks
Cherry Orchard Lane Rochford thank you
please listen very carefully
this first members offices you'll see on
the addendum recommend that this
application be deferred to enable the
applicant to provide further information
with respect to two specific matters
relating to surface water drainage and
the habitat regulations with respect to
surface water drainage there is an
expectation that major development will
incorporate surface water drainage
through sustainable urban drainage
systems details of the proposed drainage
have been submitted with the proposal
but Essex County counseled lead local
flood or thority team has raised a
holding objection requiring submission
of further information with respect to
the habitat regulations Natural England
our arrest statutory consul to to the
application and in their consultation
response advisor to habitat regulations
assessment should be carried out because
of cumulative impact of the additional
housing that that could have an impact
on the district's coastline that subject
to European wildlife legislation no such
habitat regulation assessment has been
carried out but the applicants have been
made aware of this and would like some
time to address this matter officers
have advised the applicant the officer
recommendation would likely remain one
of refusal for the reasons set out in
the development committee report but
officers consider that it is reasonable
to allow the applicant additional time
to address the two matters above which
may be resolved with the submission of
additional information including
mitigation so the recommendation from
officers Chairman is deferral of this
item I'm happy to move that
recommendation for deferral from the
chair so members if you want to have a
debate in this first instance it's
simply about whether we defer or not or
I'm happy to just go to a vote on that
one
okay so we've listened to the officers
recommendation for deferring this item
for further information
to be gathered I just have those members
in favor of deferring this item please
indicate thank you very much that items
deferred possibly january/february item
8 is public conveniences crown Hill in
Raley so members this application
relates to this site here edged in bold
on the location plan it's the old public
toilet building at the top of Crown Hill
close to the junction with the High
Street opposite the site is a public
house south of the site or some
commercial premises fronting the high
streets immediately to the sort of rear
of the site is a commercial building in
use as a gym and shop and then further
north a down south down Crown Hill the
locality is largely residential in
character but can take you to the photo
of the building that we have so this
building is within Raley Conservation
Area and the building itself is locally
listed no external changes to the
building as our proposed so the proposal
would have no adverse impact on the
character and appearance of the
conservation area could take you to the
elevation plans the application seeks to
change the use of the building to allow
for flexible uses either as a retail
shop used to within the off em financial
professional services for example as an
estate agents a restaurant cafe hot food
takeaway or as an office including light
industrial use see the floor area
proposed is just taking out all of the
toilet related equipment the floor area
is modest at some forty square meters
and it's just one one internal space the
building is located within Raley town
center where policies within the
rayleigh center area action plan apply
this plan seeks to promote Raley as the
main town center within the district and
supports planning application
which proposed use is appropriate to
this aim the action plan identifies
primary and secondary shopping areas
within the town center where there is
policy support for consolidation and
strengthening of retail developments but
the application site lies outside of
these specific town center designations
and as a consequence there's no policy
emphasis on securing only retail users
in this location it is in this location
any uses which support the vitality and
viability of the town center are to be
supported and any of the proposed uses
would fulfill this purpose and are
considered acceptable subject to the
recommended planning conditions if you
could go back to the location plan
you'll remember that there's a couple of
dwellings just north of the site so a
replacement toilet block is immediately
north to the site beyond which is some
residential properties we accept in this
general location on the edge of the town
center that there is some level of
evening sort of uses that happen but to
protect the a joint nearby residential
uses and conditions are imposed
specifically restricting the user to
close at 11:30 p.m. so subject to the
recommended planning conditions officers
recommend approval of the proposed
development councillor Steptoe Thank You
chairman just really a bit of
clarification um with the use that this
building has previously had and the
likely use for say something like
kitchen or restaurant is there any
special requirements for shall we say
deep cleaning the property
I think possibly going off the planning
issues but I think I think there'd be an
obvious need of perceived need their
share of pets would just believe that to
the plenty regulations yeah the only
control yes and I won't get there far
apart they're their score of five on the
door council Griffin Thank You chairman
do you say the buildings in the
conservation area is it only just in the
conservation area
I thought the boundary was crowding here
so goes across the road here and then
it's been extended so it takes in this
side of Crown Hill around the church so
it incorporates all of this bit so it's
not immediately on the edge of the
conservation area was a fairly recent
extension of the conservation area right
okay right thanks very much Castle mrs.
hi yeah I just wanted to ask basically
it's gonna be used for food so I'm
referring to the refuge can you explain
see where the refuge where the bins are
gonna be the thought process here is
that this is quite a small plant it's
quite difficult to uh but there is some
space to the rear of the building and
there's some space to the front but if
we go back to the picture at the front
you'll see that it's kind of landscaped
at the front and there's no plan to sort
of change that necessarily so there's a
couple of options there's a condition
that requires the applicant to provide
details of where bins are going to be
stored so what we would do is seek to
ensure that they're not ports in front
of the building because that's gonna
have a bit bit of a detrimental impact
on the character of that that particular
locality so there's a couple of options
and the site immediately north it's
under the ownership of the council as
well as far as I'm aware and so there is
potentially a ability to access the rear
to the rear of the site through this
site alternatively there's potential for
and if we go to the floor plan please
[Music]
so at the moment there isn't an access
door through there okay but it doesn't
mean to say you couldn't put one in to
enable sort of bins to be brought
forward if necessary of collection at
some suitable point in time so there is
potential for another application to
come in to put another doorway in to
allow access to the rear of the site
yes they do and it's condition so that
have to supply details to us for us to
agree before they went ahead and used
that building yeah okay castor hoc way I
know one Thank You chairman you said in
your report that the the frontage of the
building is there's no alteration
intended to an advantage at all
that's one of the usage you were talking
about here yeah so with regard to if
it's going to be for commercial use is
there any limitation or restriction on
signage on the building yes so any
signage that the potential occupier
wants to put onto that building would
have to comply with the advert
regulations the advertisement
regulations there is deemed consent for
some advert advertising on buildings and
it's quite prescriptive so the
advertising regulations are quite
lengthy we haven't got any advert
specifically proposed at the moment but
what and a potentially end user would
need to do is consider what advertising
then they want consider whether it's got
deemed consent already that wouldn't
include any illuminated advertising on
this building given that it's in the
conservation area so anything like that
would need to come before the council or
a decision so whilst there might be some
potential for some advertising that's
got deemed consent essentially deemed
consent advertisement is deemed
appropriate anyway in conservation areas
and the lettering is restricted and the
size of the advertising is constrict
they're restricted as well but we may
well see an application submitted for
for advertising
yes as I was saying about this no
alteration to the the frontage so if
someone occupied it and then they wanted
to make any alteration that would
require a planning permission I presume
then yep so because it's it's not a
dwelling house so there's no permitted
developments but if so that the
assessment is would any user want to
make a material alteration to that
building so potentially if you want to
change the appearance of the which could
include new windows and the like if it
makes a material alteration to the
building that would need planning
consent and so that would need to be an
application that was submitted council
western final one then Thank You
chairman it's probably gonna be a
difficult one anyway you've got here
about no deliveries between seven and
twenty three thirty of an evening which
obviously we know well that delivery
drivers never get here to these what are
you going to put in place I'm concerned
about this because where it is it's not
far from pedestrian crossing and traffic
lights and if you're going to have
someone who uses it as a cafe or
something like that and they're gonna
have deliveries so what I've been really
gonna be put in place the drivers are
not going to be parking at those times
of dying it will cause horrendous issues
especially up that road
so condition five is recommended the
rationale is to sort of provide try to
ensure and that the end user here on the
end use doesn't have an adverse impact
on residential amenity of the property
is further down crown Hill but we accept
that it is a town center location so it
it restricts the use and then also
deliveries to not outside of the hours
of 7:00 a.m. and 11:30 p.m. and as with
any planning condition the enforcement
is sometimes difficult doesn't mean it's
not possible but what it does mean in
these sort of circumstances is officers
if these restrictions aren't being added
to is understanding information that's
probably relayed to us from members of
the public or members getting complaints
and then investigating it and trying to
you know find instances where it's not
being adhered to obviously that's after
having spoken to the the owner and
explaining the need for them to ensure
that these these are met and that the
deliveries are within 50 minute 50
meters there is a commercial on delivery
Bay on the highest rate as well so
members it's just the principle of
whether the former toilets can have an
alternative use in this case so those
members in favor of the recommendation
printed on 8.1 please indicate was that
a yeah thank you that's a full house um
thank you
right
final item tonight 9.1 is a referred
item land to the rear of one four five
to one four nine Ferry Road home bridge
and presentation on this one mr. Strang
Thank You chairman
this application is on the to correct
the report the western side of Ferry
Road you'll see going north-south here
our site is joined in this zebra
crossing here and relates to this
building and this land area at the back
the larger building you'll see on the
site there already is a former shop
building quite a large building as
you'll see amongst a group of other
similar sized buildings that has been
converted to seven flats which are
existing occupied but there is an eighth
flat under construction if we can jump
to the topographic plan please thank you
just if members can see some of the
details but the zebra crossing is out
here the building that's already present
is here with some outbuildings members
may just be able to see at least at the
time of the survey the access goes down
this side number one four seven which
contributes the bottom of its garden to
the site the site edge rate is there
you'll see that one of the
characteristics of the site is a number
of trees that are on the site and you'll
have seen from your report that the
council's arboriculture list has
considered the submissions of the
applicant there are very culture
assigned and agrees those findings that
those trees are in very condition have
particularly poor in nature that
wouldn't amount to justifying retention
or preservation in fact there's two
trees on this boundary that are
dangerous and all be felled and there's
a further tree on this location that's
got a disease that you'll see is set out
in the report if we can go to the
superseded layout chairman there were
revisions to this application you'll see
this is the layout that first came in we
see the existing building and what
interests us is at this end of the site
you'll see the two bungalows proposed
both one bedroom bungalow is proposed
here but of interest is this extensive
car parking area it's not often
that we asked an applicant to reduce the
the car parking what I think the
philosophy was with the applicant was to
try and get full compliance which Orsi's
possible on the site but it didn't need
to do so because the scheme that was
approved here under the earlier parking
standards provided basically one space
per flat and the applicant was
interested in increasing that but
officers felt it was it was unnecessary
because the previous scheme had an
approval for just the nine spaces or so
so a reduction was sought and where
these spaces here were moved together
with I think it's the cycle of bins
store down into this more central area
convenient to that to the building and
that improved the relationship on that
side if we can go to the revised layout
this is the layout that members are
concerned with tonight this is the
application that's before you for a
decision and you'll see that the car
parking area has been reduced there is
an error in part of the report but
corrected later you'll see refer to 11
spaces this is actually 1413 at the rear
and an additional space in the front of
the building the existing building and
what the applicant also did was he
slightly changed the layout increasing
an extra window on the back but mainly
to provide independent garden spaces the
scheme that was first approved had a
communal roaming garden area around all
the buildings to do with everybody on
the site it was felt that the
application could be improved by having
independent space to serve the two
bungalows proposed now you'll see from
the report that it's actually under size
but the communal garden area over here
is a surplus and you'll see that it's
set out in the report to you that the
difference between these shortfalls is
more than made up by the surplus on the
communal side if members were concerned
about that and felt that the garden
areas should be to your standard if only
for its own sake all the applicant would
do it move the fence dividing these two
over a little bit and create more lend
to the garden area - this unit here so
he can achieve full compliance but
officers having considered that these
sites are usable these garden areas are
usable
the communal area has a better
relationship to all concerned
on balance felt that it wasn't and it
wasn't necessary to make that correction
if I can talk to you about the the
parking areas there is a correction to
paragraph 59 or the officers report
you'll see that we refer to the car
parking spaces to be two and a half by
five they're actually the old standard
that followed the layout to approving
these in the 2000s where the spaces are
four point eight by two point four now
that was that is below your minimum
standard you'll see there is some
overrun areas and these are two disabled
spaces but because the previous
approvals were to a lower standard
officers feel in this case that it's
justified to accept that four point
eight by two point four sighs that is
still consistent about in slight
conflict with the county standards that
you adopt it is consistent with the
national standards that are applied
across the country I've mentioned about
the the garden areas and the short
fulcrum make up now the members will be
aware that policy h1 to your core
strategy requires that back land
developments normally considered
unacceptable and squeezed in it requires
them to have a good relationship to the
site surroundings now you'll see that
the access that goes down this side of
the main building that's already serving
eight households it's it's already in
place so we only have the intensity of
two extra dwellings to one bedroom
they're double bedrooms but two
dwellings on the back and given the size
of the buildings that are in the front
and then the houses that back on to the
side at the back there is really a
transition in built form between the
very large former commercial properties
on this side and some residential here
to the housing more strong housing
character at the back of the site so on
balance officers feel that if we can
look at the house types and that these
buildings which are modest in scale
they've got hips rows not unlike large
garages and the pyramid type roof has
lesser form an office is consider that
this is
acceptable design in that relationship
to those surroundings but you'll see
from the recommendation it is necessary
that if members minded to approve it
that you'd have to remove permitted
development rights we feel on this
occasion for further extensions and
particularly rooms in the roof that the
rooms in the roof may or may not be
technically possible but you'll be aware
that the government is or has considered
whether to change PD rights to allow
lifting of the roofs so as a matter of
housekeeping officer's support the idea
of removing the PD rights for these two
dwellings before I moved to the
recommendation chairman there is one
further submission we've had since the
addendum was produced it's not addressed
but I do need to read it to you it says
further to our previous comments
relating to the above planning
application our position remains the
same
we are totally opposed to the building
of these two bungalows at the rear of
our garden in Elm Grove for all the
reasons mentioned in our last email it
would also appear updated plans have
also recently been submitted which would
like some clear clarification on these
as they indicate further elevations
which from our point of view would be
totally unacceptable
I argent Li await further comments
Chairman's the recommendation is
approval subject to the conditions that
are set out in the report thank you have
a speaker
it just doesn't market up to five
minutes I look now when you've got
good evening I speak on behalf of the
residents of Elm Grove and also
one-nine-five at 149 very Road I firstly
raised the point that the owners at
149th very Road are in consultation with
their solicitor with regard to a
potential boundary dispute there's been
raised the said boundary be between 1
for 9 and 1 for 7 the boundary of 1 for
9 and the north side of the development
at present is separated by trees the
first Dean to be on the site of bond for
9 ferry roads I understand the boundary
has been moved to the benefit of the
owners of bond for 7 and if successful I
consider the lands were gained by 1/4 or
9 would reduce the available land
available to development quite
considerably
the plans indicate the removal of her
said trees and the loss of the trees
would impact in the privacy of the
owners 4 1 4 9 considerably it would
also be impossible for the owners of 1 4
9 to build their own screen of trees is
there some important Institute's the
boundary of no scope to plant I also
note that 1 4 9 ferry road remains noted
on the application despite it being
raised previously that the owners of
that property are not making the
planning application for me this raises
further questions about around whose
layer the application is actually being
made on if we look at the photo the
aerial photo of the property we see the
ambiguous pattern of the boundary and
actually you know for my part you can
see where there's a bit of garage built
at the top that and part Lagarde has
been taken I can cut the proposed
dwellings would be an over development
of the area
they'll be in Congress an alien form of
development there would not be well
integrated into local built environment
and so be a discordant feature that
would detract from the character and
appearance of the area and does not
conform to the regular Street pattern
and in conflict the core strategy policy
h1 + h p6 the Botsford districts plan
I consider be an accessible form of
background development that goes against
the polite policy guidelines regarding
building in back gardens this I think if
this passes it will take a president if
there's a lot of land that's just left
behind all those houses that could open
the gateway for a complete estate report
in between the Barry Road and Elm Grove
I would argue also there is no need for
black land development due to the 500
plus homes already passed by yourselves
in whole bridge we also consider that
the proposed development is situated too
close to the boundary of the surrounding
properties was in impacts on privacy
when increase of noise and disturbance
and I think also the being projected
going up into the roofs of the house is
also that would also impact on us great
war greater than we even believed before
because you know that wood will be
overlooked completely then there'll be
noise and disturbance having effectively
a car park or joining our back garden
LED lights shining into our bedroom
windows as vehicles drive into the
development would also affect us greatly
and cause as much disturbance additional
vehicles associated is develop would
have an adverse effect on local divert
movement of traffic which ways for me
safety concerns as the vehicles would
have difficulty in turning around within
the development and so it need to
reverse out to the main road and nearby
the zebra cross in mistreated access
also raise his safeguarding concerns and
respected the difficulties emergency
vehicles would have in excess and the
properties and if you see the photo
that's been submitted there was an
incident where it actually emergency
vehicle had to get into that property
and their great difficulty as you can
see by the photo taken trying to get
down to the side with two bungalows in
that background development I do
question that's an ambulance at the fire
engine get down there and I presume in
there behind it disabled people they are
perhaps the only people living in the
bungalows
quite frequently in the need for
ambulances I don't think that is
acceptable
I am right if we also look at the photo
flooding that remains an issue and
there's some photos at the back garden
one four nine butter one four seven is
elevated and so these are these photos
here of actual flagging that's occurred
because of the one four seven sits
behind that fence that's all thanks as a
damn for that garden so I don't know how
the flooding could be rectified there's
any planes or thank you I say a parking
number of spaces potentially you could
have quite a number of people living in
those flats I don't beat the park inside
to quote that purse put onto the
surrounding areas
and I'm also conserved the people that
actually live in there already because
they're actually living in the building
society actual buildings and been
undertaken in inside their flats while
they live in there I don't think that's
acceptable in this day and age okay and
also I'm concerned about the abuse of
process if we had no idea this meetings
will go on this evening it was only that
my neighbor saw on the website we had no
formal notification that actually this
wasn't going to be the report had been
given so I don't really find that's
acceptable either thank you counselor
mr. hoi
Thank You chairman then just two or
three points I'd like to raise on on
this one for me thank you
first I'd like to start with the amine
as he space amenity space should be
usable and we do state that in our
policy useful amenity space I understand
that the and correct me if I'm wrong
please I'm sure you know you will do
that the amenity space we've shown is
useful is the actual Gardens we are
excluding the bits to the side and to
the backs of the bungalows themselves
and we are just the amenity space is
just a as in front at it just for
clarity the properties so we are
excluding the bit to the side and the H
when we talk about the 41 square meters
and the formation we slew this area yes
but we're including the testis could you
sit out in it and so a narrow meter side
space that is normally just there to
give the buildings and adding court
setting they're really little more than
walkways but if it's wider than a than a
walkway it can be included so we've
measured these almost Dale shaped areas
behind the building thank you but you're
excluding the one on the far side thank
you and I on that base I still contend
that the mean squares isn't usable to
the extent it should be that the main
space is to the rear of the plots it's
quite a distance from the flats and the
flats of the main users of the amenity
space the amenity space itself is the
area directly it goes directly to the
edge of the bungalows underneath there
but windows looking at the planes so
that in reality that is not usable you
can't expect people to to be playing
underneath the bungalows for young
children it to me this is where the
usable space has to be applied and I
contend that that is not useable on the
second point
I'm going back to the parking cause
obviously I do note the parking sizes
which were putting the report minimum
parking standards a two point nine by
five point five meters but we are
allowed to have a minimum space
exceptionally of two point five by five
meters and we actually say that any less
than that makes the space is not usable
a paraphrase slightly almost a bit just
because parking spaces if a smaller size
may have being part of an earlier
application on an earlier application
which had different standards does not
mean in my opinion that we should keep
those minimum standards which now are
outdated we should try and modernize and
update and we should preferably have two
point nine by five point five but as
I've been told previously at the minimum
two point five by five should be there
it I don't know Wahby
we're going lower and again there's no
demonstration that the park is faces
could the required number of parking
spaces could if we team to those sizes
but I really do think we should be
keeping to our current minimum standards
not outdated minimum standards they are
the two major points I'd like to raise
the other one I would like to just
queries about the bin storage on short
councillor stepped over advice for your
this if no one else came I couldn't see
a point can we have clarification where
the bins will be if it's going to be in
the main bin storage or they've got this
everyone is so the the bin storage will
contain the bins for all flats and the
two bungalows and that being storages
within the minimum distance chairman the
entry for point for the refuse vehicle
yes chairman that but the the communal
area there is for the flats obviously
the houses having their own amenity
space they'd be able to have their own
bin storage in their own gardens they
can def date and there is room in the
gardens for their bins yes chairman you
you can see the the space that there is
that's fine yeah I can see space but I
just would need to know that they
that has been thought of where they keep
you and that takes me back to the point
there there is a minimum distance which
I did not have time to look up one is I
want to know does the refuse vehicle go
down the side access to collect the bins
or do they walk up to get the bins there
is a minimum distance that they expect
you to walk so one clarification around
there if the bun glows of that much the
bun clothes are further away than the
existing bin storage and the proposed
being storage not just like
clarification around that thank you
obviously I because you remember
obviously you haven't got chance to come
back so he's just happy with what you've
said yeah okay that's the Western thank
you [ __ ] thank chairman I want to go
this is one poori for this solicitor II
the the resident said there was a
dispute between the boundaries at one
four nine and one for seven a bit
concerned on this because if there is a
dispute of the boundary as a district
are we correct in allowing an
application to go through if we say yes
so should we not be refusing this on
this faces until that is sorted sorry
it's just a question yeah I can recall
this one quite clearly from training the
principle of whether something can
happen the planning application is
irrespective of who owns the land it's
the principle of whether that can happen
that we're discussing who actually owns
the land or boundary disputes they're
not that's a separate issue not part of
the application tonight so the answer to
your question it's not relevant to what
we're discussing sorry chairman I don't
understand that because if we're
discussing ultimately I don't own the
land you can't develop on it I'm saying
this on the lane now so if we say yes to
it and yet doesn't own the land and
it goes through are we not as a district
well okay thank you planning law That's
not me sorry and yeah the only thing I'd
like to know well if it's one four five
to one four nine and they submitted the
plan notation from one four five to one
four nine yeah
something but surely the paperwork's
wrong name because they don't own one
four nine
that's it works but counselor mrs. Frank
song chairman if I may I think the
inclusion of one four nine could
actually be our error when we when we
identify sites we go to be LP u dots and
I think because of the history and the
site and that I think we may have
inadvertently included number four one
four nine the site is number one four
seven and the applicants have certified
the ownership between the two properties
so that there may be some issues you
heard raised by third parties and as the
chair is clarified if you get planning
permission you can't build that
permission if you don't own the full
extent of the site you need the consent
of the landowner
but the applicants it seems from the
application forms of identified decide
to be 1 4 5 and 1 4 7 and serve notice
on number 1 for 7 whether there is in
reality some sort of encroachment of
boundaries including number 1 4 9 as
you've heard I can't clarify further for
you we have we got an answer for the bin
distance sorry
the guidance that you refer to is 25
meters for the collection this is some
some 46 meters or so so the site
occupiers would have to put their bins
out to a reception area for the
operatives to collect and empty the bins
Okwe
Thank You chairman your answers select
that so last questions gives me a
question do you say that there's a
parking space allocated to the front of
the flats surely that if there is a
requirement for residents to put their
bins out so that the the operatives can
collect them that parking space will be
irrelevant because they were using a
Savino collection in bins go on the
highway not on the side
another question that I recently was
thinking about did you state that there
was a couple of parking spaces which
were for disability are is it intended
for these bungalows to be for people
with disabilities Chairman I don't think
they're designed specifically for people
with ability their disabilities in terms
of like wet room bathrooms and
purpose-made facilities I say in the
report what the applicant has said in
their submissions that they anticipate
they don't know but they anticipate that
in a sort of quiet setting at the back
here the disabled spaces were putting
because they anticipate these buildings
might be attractive to either elderly
people or people with disabilities
because of their suitability to that
market but you know we can't say who
would take take those units on car
parking the applicant has clarified that
in the management of the site each site
occupier would be dedicated one space so
there'd be ten of the spaces given over
to one each to all the all the
households that would leave for as a
casual visitor parking surplus capacity
etc if that helps Jim councillor Wilson
- Thank You chairman um can I just go
refer to the diagram in front of us the
is there actually a physical boundary
for the shared amenity area which is on
the top of the diagram there and then
you've got the the area to the left of
it
so is there actually some sort of
physical boundary because that's a
shared area and sort of supplementary
questions ladies with the figures the
calculations that have been made for the
immediate area does that include the new
flat that's being built chairman
there's boundary demarcation on this
plan submitted before you here and
through the middle of the site here
giving to private amenity errors that
have been described to you in the report
I can't my eyes aren't good enough to
see if there's a demarcation there it
probably wouldn't be because there's
landscaping and then it's a communal
area the 8th flat your your amenity
space policies allow for a balcony and
there is a balcony feature detail in
there so that doesn't need the reliance
has been approved anyway with the
balcony but it doesn't need reliance on
that space thank you
and just a point on the the parking
space sizes if we were to remove the for
visitor spaces would there be enough
space for 10 correct or - policy size
spaces or is that being thought of
Shemin the initial layout that you saw
that the applicant put in obviously
relied on more land that they felt they
could provide in there so if you was to
condition a consent to say you want the
cart parking spaces to be that 200 mil
wider and a hundred mil longer sorry the
of around 100 mil wide wide and 200 mil
longer they could probably get that
compliance in there
it's how that might ultimately impact
upon the overall amenity provision
particularly if you was thinking of the
way it works out because the the point
I'm making the report is members are
right we have standards
if things wouldn't improve if it didn't
move on the problem you've got is being
considered reasonable if you were to
refuse permission on that basis would a
government inspector as we suspect come
in to the site and see that the car
parking spaces that were approved were
to a certain size okay things move on
but is it reasonable rather than just
for its own sake in this case on this
site to require the larger space it
would definitely beneficial to the users
but is it something that makes a
difference between refusing plan
admission and approving it and on this
occasion officers have felt weighing
that up because of the presence of the
existing spaces and what an inspector
might think we don't know because we're
not add an appeal but we have to advise
you on what the chances may be and we
felt strong enough that in this case we
should go with the size of the spaces
that are submitted I think one of the
other mitigating factors on the car
parking space is is that as you look at
the plan a good number of them are sort
of end spaces where there it although
the actual marking of the Bay is is the
lower size they have got side space as
well so it's effectively a more usable
area against a lot where you want to
come back yes I understand
what our officer has expressed in
relation to the parking spaces but we
it's not just a case of you know
vehicles sizes I've got bigger generally
and we are also looking to help people
with you know the likelihood is that
some of these properties be occupied
with people who have young children
and you know the requirement for them to
be have access to their vehicles and be
able to put you know young children into
vehicles you don't know safe manner I
think it's appropriate that we look to
try and meet our minimum standards if
it's a matter of adjusting the plan
slightly to do that they know if that's
something that could be done by
condition without actually having to
refuse the application in total members
I think we've had a good debate at at
this point and covered the principles
there's a bit of an impasse over the
over the parking standards but we do
have to bear in mind the standards that
were applied at the application that
does have an approval so we'll move to
the vote on this there's the
recommendation printed on nine point one
point one eight going through to nine
point one point twenty the various
conditions those members in favor of the
approval please indicate
those against my vote voted against
thank you okay thank you that item is
approved thank you very much for your
attendance evening